In order to be brave,
you've got to be a little bit scared
I need you to be brave right now
You ever miss it?
I haven't touched a gun in ten years
After what happened that night
FBI, SHOW ME YOUR HANDS
I just put my sword down, you know?
Without that bad luck
(You're gonna be ok)
I never would have met Sarah
I never would have had my kids
Daddy loves who?
Me! Me! ME!
I love you
You'd better!
Mr Sawyer, you are the very first family we have had
in the residential section of the Pearl
After your security assessment, what do you think of the building?
The Pearl is the most advanced super-tall structure in the world
It's a breathtaking achievement
But...?
No one really knows what would happen if things go wrong
[whistles]
Hello boys
Let it burn
The 96th floor is on fire
Sarah, listen to be - the fire is not going to stop
Keep going up, don't stop, don't look back
OK
Get back! WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA! You don't understand, my family is in there
Turn around!
Ok, don't looks down
That was dumb
How did you get in the building?!
Jumped off a super-crane
What?!
Just the man I was looking for
This building
Is protecting something that I want
You're going to get it for me
Anything can be done, with the proper motivation
NO!
DADDY!
We gotta do this together
I'm scared
It's OK to be scared
In order to be brave, you've got to be a little scared
I gotta get you outta this building - I need you to be brave right now, OK?
Yeah
Daddy loves who?
Me
Hold on!
3...
2...
1!
I'll do whatever it takes
to keep my family safe